ont commis un attentat sur le territoire
qui doivent être condamnés
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 7 octobre à six
mois de la présidentielle marine le pen
contre attaque la candidate du
rassemblement national en perte de
vitesse dans les sondages s'adresse
directement à eric zemmour et lui
demande de clarifier ses intentions le
polémiste toujours pas officiellement
candidat mais qui fait désormais office
de chamboule-tout dans la campagne du
côté du rnd aussi des républicains hier
pour la première fois une enquête harris
interactive le placer au second tour
alors étoiles filantes ou hypothèse
crédible eric zemmour oblige-t-il des
candidats se repositionner les partis
traditionnels sont ils vraiment menacée
le débat est ouvert
emmanuel macron lui non plus n'est
toujours pas officiellement candidat à
sa réélection mais il multiplie les
déplacements en région direction
montpellier demain où il lancera le
sommet afrique-france afrique-france
nouvelle formule pas de présidents
africains invités cette année mais une
société civile mise à l'honneur pourtant
certaines associations des syndicats et
des partis politiques veulent dénoncer
la face cachée du nouveau sommet afrique
france un collectif a décidé
d'interpeller président en organisant un
contre sommet
et au sommaire à 21h les crises du coc
vide en france il n'y aura pas
d'allègements du pass sanitaire avant le
15 novembre
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le porte parole du
gouvernement pour gabriela talent
l'heure de levée des contraintes n'est
pas venu mais les tests de dépistage
dits de confort deviendront
même bien payant le 15 octobre comme
prévu il faudra débourser 44 euros pour
un pcr 22 euros au moins pour un
antigénique est ce la bonne stratégie
alors que l'épidémie marque le pas
décryptage dans une heure
[Musique]
eric zemmour prix et donc de déclarer sa
candidature par honnêteté vis-à-vis des
français marine le pen a lancé cet appel
aux polémistes aujourd'hui lors d'un
déplacement en auvergne à six mois de la
présidentielle la candidate du r n
entend bien occuper le terrain menacé
sur sa droite par eric zemmour on
retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
n'a déjà des rasades devant le siège du
rassemblement national bonsoir nadège
eric zemmour qui jouent décidément les
trouble fête à droite dans cette
campagne marine le pen elle contre
attaque aujourd'hui
absolument stéphanie eric maintenant tu
dois être candidat marine le pen appelle
le polémiste a clarifié sa position en
vue de l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 la présidente du rassemblement
national perd des points dans les
sondages au fur et à mesure et qu'eric
zemmour en gagne un sondage harris
interactive le place désormais au second
tour du scrutin avec 17 % à des
intentions de vote 15% pour marine le
pen en déplacement au sommet de
l'élevage à clermont ferrand la
présidente du rassemblement national
n'affiche pas forcément d'inquiétude
particulière elle estime que les
sondages disent tout l inverse de tous
et jamais la même chose
on ne peut pas débattre avec les cas qui
n'est pas encore candidat moi j'ai à
dire à éric écoute méric maintenant il
faut que tu sois candidat c'est une
question aussi un peu de loyauté
vis-à-vis des français un peu
d'honnêteté politique il faut que chacun
annonce sa candidature
et puis quand tout le monde aura annoncé
sa candidature et bien des échanges
pourront avoir lieu
il neige la patronne du fn qui met en
avant un programme bien défini
contrairement à celui d'eric zemmour
selon elle en tout cas
marine le pen qui je cite ne vois pas
bien la plus value que pourrait apporter
eric zemmour sur des sujets régaliens
comme l'immigration ou l'insécurité je
retrouve dans sa bouche des propositions
que nous faisions il y a longtemps dit
elle en évoquant ses campagnes de 2012
et 2017 elle estime qu'il n'y a pour
l'heure pas matière à débattre avec eric
zemmour puisqu'il n'est pas
officiellement candidat qu'il n'a pas de
programme ni de propositions alors au
sein du rassemblement national certains
estiment que marine le pen a eu sa
chance plus d'une fois et qu'elle aurait
dû laisser sa place à jordan bardella
grand vainqueur des dernières élections
européennes en france
merci nadège ad razak en direct donc du
siège du rl et quoi qu'il en soit eric
zemmour rebat les cartes d'une campagne
qui se lancent étoiles filantes ou
hypothèse crédible il donne en tout cas
du fil à retorde aux partis
traditionnels qu'ils obligent parfois à
revoir leur stratégie c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire arnaud
benedetti vous êtes également
spécialiste du décryptage de la
communication politique bonsoir alexis
libye sur ce plateau éditorialistes rt
france bonsoir alexis enfin benjamin
cauchy
conseiller en communication et prochain
d'eric zemmour bonsoir et merci à tous
les trois d'être là je ne suis pas
chambouler essaye de se convaincre et de
nous convaincre marine le pen ce matin
elle refusé de nommer jusqu'à l'âme
alors maintenant elle appelle eric et
surtout elle l'appelle à sortir du bois
et à enfin se déclarer benjamin cauchy
vous le proche d'eric zemmour est ce que
c'est pour bientôt cette déclaration de
candidature je crois en tout cas que
s'il a envie d'y aller on n'a jamais été
aussi proche une fois que j'ai dit ça je
les ai rien dit en tout état de cause ce
n'est pas madame le pen de déterminer
calendrier d'eric zemmour a aujourd'hui
il est vous savez dans une phase de
réflexion allant à la rencontre des à la
rencontre des français il fait des
conférences littéraires il fait des
déplacements
avec les chefs d'entreprise il va
visiter des usines mon bref il est en
train de prendre le pouls pour savoir
s'il a vraiment ou pas y aller donc je
sais que tout le monde de pia et
d'impatience à savoir quand est-ce qu'il
va se décider mais long ça il faut
raison garder il faut raison garder
c'est pas parce que les sondages donnent
à 17% aujourd'hui qui était un très beau
résultat qui va déclencher une
candidature immédiatement ça se mûrit
une candidature mais manifestement
arnaud benedetti d'ailleurs eric zemmour
le dit lui même il y a dix il l'a dit
sur rtl il ya trois semaines c'est mon
intérêt de faire durer l'ambiguïté quand
on crée du suspense évidemment on crée
du désir c'est bien connu désir qui
risquerait de s'effilocher au au moment
de de cette déclaration
oui cette femme au est nommé désir d'une
certaine manière la réalité c'est qu'en
fait le conti ils essayent de maîtriser
sa communication dans le but de créer
les conditions justement d'un élan et
d'un appel
d'une partie de la droite en sa faveur
sa communication de ce point de vue là
et est assez bien rodée elle est assez
habile il crée vous l'avez dit du
suspense il crée un intérêt il suscite
une attention et il en profite surtout
pour bouleverser les deux blocs
d'électorat de droite que son
l'électorat de droite des républicains
et l'électorat de droite du
rassemblement national parce que toute
la stratégie des examens aujourd'hui
c'est finalement de décloisonner c'est
deux offres politiques et de les réunir
autour de sa candidature
il profite en plus diffuser des
tergiversations qui sont celles des
républicains qui pour l'instant ne sont
pas sortis de leurs problèmes de
procédure pour désigner un candidat même
si formellement le congrès aujourd'hui
des républicains doit se tenir le gros
lot 4 décembre doc il a tout intérêt sur
un plan tactique à ce stade finalement
de poursuivre cette cette forme
d'engagement à travers notamment des
conférences qu'il donne au tour de
survivants alors c'est vrai que alexis
poulain
xavier bertrand s'y est pas trompé il
exhorte la droite à se rassembler en fin
et à et a décidé en attendant en
entendant lui eric zemmour se dit le
candidat de la droite celle du rpr des
années 80 c
vous le voyez comme ça avoue eric
zemmour
non on peut difficilement le voir comme
ça vouloir faut vraiment remonter très
loin au premier discours de jacques
chirac à voir comment il était radical
lorsqu'il a fait fonder le rpr mais
heureux c'est enfin on est en 2021 par
contre là où eric zemmour a raison c'est
qu'à l'époque du rpr il y avait un
centre droit qui existait il y avait ces
deux droites irréconciliables et donc ce
que veut faire aiguiser moore
aujourd'hui c'est tout simplement
revenir à cet état de fait c'est-à-dire
exploser ce bloc l'ump d'abord et puis
les lr ensuite parce qu'il n'a plus de
raison d'être quand vous avez d'un côté
le maire de nice qui avoue maintenant
ouvertement être un support des modèles
macro et de l'autre côté eric ciotti a
voisin du maire de nice qui dit non moi
je voterai zemmour au deuxième tour
comment voulez vous que ces deux
personnes soient dans le même parti donc
aujourd'hui l'ump comme l air a vécu
alors c'est à partie qui vit encore qui
va c'est essayer d'exister avec le
congrès mais même le timing de ce
congrès décembre c'est beaucoup trop
tard
quel champion va sortir du chapeau
valérie pécresse d'un côté xavier
bertrand de l'autre et puis les autres
on ne sait pas vraiment eric zemmour
arrive et là il fait accélérer le temps
politique en disant simplement ça suffit
l'hypocrisie ce suffit de faire semblant
il est temps de trouver votre camp à
droite alors ça peut faire perdre la
droite évidemment et ça peut profiter
avec nos lagons qui va devenir le
nouveau pôle de droite centriste les
gens vont aller vers lui d'ailleurs
edouard philippe lançon partie samedi
c'est pas pour rien c'est pour conter
pouces et deux modem un peu plus loin et
être un peu le pilier de cette fameuse
maison commune qui va donner à emmanuel
macron le socle de droite pour être le
candidat de la droite centriste alors à
propos de la droite regardez cette
couverture du
the telegraph
le journal britannique va s'afficher à
l'écran dans quelques secondes
clairement ils révolutionnent la droite
eric zemmour benjamin cauchy c'est votre
opinion aussi oui je pense qu'il est en
train de mettre un bon coup de pied dans
la fourmilière en train de renverser sur
la table comme dirait le président
underwood pour secondes la référence de
cette bonne série netflix plus
sérieusement il en train de parler à
deux électorats et monsieur benedetti
disais justement on revient de 31 % des
gens qui ont voté le pen en 2017
seraient prêts à voter et xénon dimanche
prochain est exactement cette même
proportion de 31 % des républicains qui
souhaiteraient voté pour pour eric
zemmour donc il reprend effectivement
les les fondamentaux du rpr il part d'un
choc des civilisations il parle à la
raison des gens et non pas à l'émotion
des gens certains disent qu'ils flattent
les peurs au contraire je pense qu'il
parle à la raison et on tombe loin de là
de de toute cette émotion habituel des
politiques qui veulent nous faire
pleurer sur des situations
catastrophiques pour distiller des idées
progressistes mais pour le coup eric
zemmour il parle avec quand même une
pointe de conservatisme mais
relativement ouvert le conservatisme ça
ne pas dire on s'arrête le conservatisme
ça veut dire on avance doucement donc il
en train de mettre un point un point
d'ancrage sur le choc de civilisations
il entrave attirer des gens de partout
donc oui il révolutionne la droite parce
que pour une fois la droite va retrouver
une colonne vertébrale idéologique
qu'elle a perdue depuis de nombreuses
années et puis la deuxième chose je
l'espère en tout cas nous l'espérons
s'assoit l'électrochoc organique et
réorganiser la droite puisque vous
l'avez dit tous effectivement à
l'explosif façon puzzle arnaud benedetti
d'accord avec ce diagnostic que fait
benjamin cauchy parce que les ailes et
au delà de la gauche et de la droite
c'est aussi être le candidat antisystème
qui est peut-être justement dans dans
l'air du temps non mais clairement
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il existe
depuis un certain nombre d'années un
rejet que l'on peut qualifier d'anti
système dont eric zemmour profite et
incarne parce que il a pour lui à la
fois une forme de radicalité dans
l'expression dans l'est dans les propos
et il a pour lui la cohérence de cette
radicalité dans la durée parce que le
diagnostic qu'il fait sur l'état de la
société en fait c'est un diagnostic qui
date de plusieurs années qu'aliment
depuis la parution de son livre le
suicide français en 2013 ou 2014 donc de
hilla il a fait cohérent c'est cette
intériorité il le crédibilise skis le
crédibilise aussi c'est que finalement
il y a du côté du rassemblement national
qui amène constitue malgré tout quand on
regarde les études d'opinion sa zone de
chalandise électorale principal pour
l'instant même s'il prend d'accord une
partie des républicains notamment des
anciens électeurs le sioniste mais il se
trouve que du côté du rassemblement
national marine le pen avec sa politique
de dédiabolisation a ouvert un espace
politique et l espace politique et a
occupé par son père qui aujourd'hui est
à découvert et dans lequel évidemment
eric zemmour on puise abondamment à la
fois sur le plan lexical mais également
sur le plan d un certain nombre de
propositions
alexis poulain pour vous eric zemmour un
candidat crédible ou finalement
quelqu'un qui comme moi sont infinies
d'ailleurs
pardonnez moi et comme il se définit
lui-même quelqu'un finalement de
visionnaire mais qui peut-être n'apporte
pas toujours des solutions concrètes en
une candidature à la présidentielle
s'est beaucoup de dilemme bien sûr il
est d'abord polémiste il n'est pas
encore candidat donc pas de programme
mais ça rappelle quelqu'un vous aviez un
ancien ministre qui se déclarent qu a
pas de partie et qui gagne et il ya la
même mécanique derrière quand j'entends
eric zemmour candidat antisystème quand
on voit le nombre de couvertures de
magazine qui l'a fait la façon dont on
en parle tout le temps dans les médias
il est absolument dans le système il est
poussé par les médias d'ailleurs
certains se demandent si on n'en fait
pas trop s'il est crédible ça c'est une
fois qu'il sera candidat qu'il va
rentrer dans le débat politique qu'on va
voir s'il est crédible aujourd'hui il se
permet tout il reste polémiste il fait
une campagne marketing phénoménal pour
son livre et il est en campagne en même
temps sans le dire un peu comme emmanuel
macron donc là c'est facile pour lui
c'est facile ça pour vous et la faute
aux médias justement parce que c'est une
voix qu'on entend beaucoup ça n'aurait
plus mois à la faute aux médias qui le
pousse médias de milliardaires parce
qu'eric zemmour finalement ils ne
dérangent pas vous avez des candidats
déclarés aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont
jamais testé dans les sondages qui son
invisibilité eric zemmour il est poussé
il est comme sur un tapis volant parce
que'il arrange et mode macro il arrange
beaucoup de gens et finalement il
récupère le travail de longue haleine de
long terme de la famille le pen et sa
chance à lui eric zemmour c'est que ce
n'est pas un héritier il n'est pas un
héritier le pen et en plus comme le dit
jean marie le pen il peut pas être taxé
d'antisémitisme même s'il défend pétain
c'est formidable alors là c'est un
camouflet que ce total de la droite et
l'extrême droite donc oui il a un
boulevard mais parce qu'on le pousse
aujourd'hui personne quand on n'y a eu
aucun débat avec jean luc mélenchon
c'est le seul qui a dit allons-y vous
avez toute une partie de la gauche qui a
nom ne faut surtout pas débattre avec
eric zemmour va alors quel est l'intérêt
vous pouvez ce qu'on crée quand est ce
qu'on fait de la politique donc lui
aujourd'hui c'est facile j'attends de
voir une fois qu'il va être candidat
benjamin cauchy oui bah écoutez je sens
poindre l'impatience en vous monsieur
poulin j'essaierai même de vous trouver
un t-shirt fait zemmour pas la guerre si
vous voulez sur ça vous irait à
merveille
c'est honnêtement honnêtement c'est
peut-être facile tout simplement parce
que il c'est le symptôme du vide comme
disait monsieur sarkozy dans une
interview et quelques jours et que les
républicains que le voyou venir ou non
pardonnez moi les quatre impétrants à la
candidature ces derniers laissent pas
lourd quoi ça pèse pas lourd en terme de
visibilité de notoriété de ligne
politique véritablement parce qu'on se
dit c'est ça le différend une fiente et
est donc ça pour le coup eric zemmour
c'est facile pour lui parce qu'il n'y a
pas grand monde chez les républicains
parce que marine le pen est quelque part
effectivement perdu entre eux sept
billets dédiabolisation et puis ses
fondamentaux
en revanche
qu'ils soient en campagne ou pas c'est
quand même intéressant que depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est lui qui décide
du thème de la campagne donc il ya deux
choses qu'on va distinguer il
effectivement l'effervescence médiatique
autour de lui qui fait qu'il s'accapare
on va dire du temps d'antenne à ce qu'il
fait vendre aussi un moment donné faut
que les médias soient honnêtes
effectivement les audiences augmente
quand eric zemmour parle donc forcément
ça fait vendre c'est une réalité
économique il serait malhonnête de ne
pas le cas chez orange qui n'en voulait
pas à l'époque on s'entend faire de
seignosse assez sur la forme et moi je
redonne cette responsabilité à la
réflexion aux médias de réfléchir à cela
monsieur c'est le citoyen qui s'exprime
en revanche sur le fond eric zemmour a
quand même réussi à imposer son thème
celui du choc des civilisations
donc on peut on peut le rail et dire que
c'est facile parce qu'il n'est pas
candidat on peut le rail est parce qu il
fait du le pen - belgique emmène ses
huit mois le rail et parce qu'il ya des
milliers de jeunes qui le qui le qui le
rejoignent parce qu'il ya des centaines
de contacts par jour qui viennent dans
les amis d'eric zemmour parce que les
femmes avec zemmour montre qu eric
zemmour n'est pas un vieux sexiste telle
est l'image que certains gauche on
voudrait donner donc voilà donc non
c'est pas si facile que ça pour encore
les femmes apparaissent que le pouvoir
se dissipe ou une sortie comme ça
c'était pas classement l'appétit pour
les quelques sorties pour le salon qu'il
faisait quand même phrase il sortait de
phrase du contexte j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un autre podium mais
représente un petit port tout cas quand
on défend la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne et que l'on souhaite
l'égalité entre les hommes et des femmes
je pense que dans d'autres pays
malheureusement vous seriez voilée pour
présenter journal nous sommes en france
et heureusement les femmes n'ont pas
l'obligation d'être voilée c'est une
défense de la civilisation quand on
défend cette civilisation
judéo-chrétienne on défend l'égalité
hommes femmes on ne peut pas lui faire
ce procès on va se retourner vers arnaud
benedetti arnaud vdt petit justement
quand on vous entendez ce petit combat
là entre alexis poulin et benjamin
cauchy
justement eric zemmour porté par par ces
médias ou c'est un faux procès
mais je pense qu'il est quand même
fondamentalement très attractif
médiatiquement et ce depuis de très
nombreuses années si vous voulez eric
zemmour il n'apparaît pas depuis six
mois dans le paysage médiatique c'est
quelqu'un qui depuis 20 ans et sur les
plateaux télévision acquis une humilité
médiatique de plus en plus importante et
a construit discours politique qui l'a
rendu d'une certaine manière audible
audible parce que aussi une partie peut
être de la droite à avais je pense
notamment au rpr abandonner une partie
de ses fondamentaux donc il est à la
fois en effet malgré tout le produit de
l'intérêt des médias il est produit de
l'intérêt des médias ham est il des
produits d'intérêt des médias parce que
tout simplement et clairement france
lille est sur un plateau de télé vidéo
et ben fois il fait de l'audience c'est
une réalité et en politique sa coupe
outils en effet et la clé c'est vrai
pourquoi fait-il les audiences merci je
suis passé par l'ol france un objectif
parce que il a un discours qui a été
abandonné par une partie de la classe
politique notamment sur la question par
exemple migratoires donc il occupe un
espace que les politiques ont laissé
vraisemblement en jachère et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il fait d'audience
il fait de l'audience comme jean marie
le pen faisait une audience dans les
années 80 il faut se souvenir que jean
marie le pen était considéré à la fois
comme le diable mais en même temps comme
un excellent client pour les médias mais
on a un phénomène avec eric zemmour sauf
que entre temps trente années se sont
passées trente années de vie publique
quand années de vie politique et trente
années de fractal isation et de
balkanisation de la société française
c'est sa doudou les scores dans les
sondages et le fait que maintenant parce
que on a ce camp centriste de la
bien-pensance de européiste aussi où on
doit aplanir absolument tout la culture
française n'existait pas pour l emmanuel
macron quand même le président de la
république qui dit une chose pareille
évidemment que c'étaient des blessures
pour les français et donc il est le seul
à le dire il a eu en plus toute latitude
en étant polémiste pour le dire avec
véhémence maintenant candidat moi je
crains qu'il ne soit obligé de revenir
sur quelques déclarations il a déjà fait
sur l'art migration par exemple lors du
débat lundi soir dont je n'ai jamais
dire aux migrations or il l'a dit
plusieurs fois et donc là il risque de
perdre un peu de cette attractivité du
polémiste parce que oui ça peut marcher
tant qu'on n'est pas politique et qu'on
doit pas faire ce consensus pour essayer
de rassembler large mais aujourd'hui
c'est le vide qui remplit à partir du
moment où il va commencer à voir des
gens qui viennent de la droite de
l'extrême droite peut-être d'ailleurs
qui vont commencer à dire ah mais si on
faisait quelque chose ça va être
différent non je pense qu'il va remplir
encore plus pour votre expression il
remplit rempli j'aime pas trop l'image
mais
non sur évidemment ça c'est plutôt
symptomatique et comme quoi c'est pas
qu'une bulle médiatique justement d'en
faire un parallèle avec les jets
précédents aucune bulle numérique avec
des digital soldiers des trolls comme
comme on dit maintenant qui serait en
charge de faire monter subrepticement
eric zemmour non il ya une réalité il ya
une lame de fond il ya une présence
militante ce que je disais juste avant
donc soyez présence militante qui
représente quoi précisément parce que en
attendant on relève n'est pas candidat
on l'a dit les 500 parrainages c'est pas
qu'on n'en parle jamais mais c'est
peut-être aussi un un sujet et surtout
un appareil derrière une machine de
campagne qu'il faudra le jour u2 se
lancera ce qu'il est prêt de ce point de
vue là c'est en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que l'association des
amis d'eric zemmour une association qui
reçoit des centaines de contacts au
quotidien et que effectivement dans
chaque département dans des cantons dre
circonscriptions les gens se réunissent
cette association bénéficie de dons donc
elle peut leur permettre de leur envoyer
des affiches donc il ya une
communication qui est fait sur le
terrain bien une communication numérique
qui existent également disons que le
bateau amiral attend son capitaine tout
simplement mais ce bateau amiral se
construira en temps et en heure en tout
cas tout le monde s'y prépare et ce
qu'ils étaient ce qui est vraiment
particulière c'est pas pour faire langue
de bois ou quoi que ce soit mais je
regarde cette campagne parce que je suis
proche d'eric zemmour et que je partage
quelques unes de ses idées messieurs je
la regarde aussi je l'observent si vous
voulez et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
voir tous ces primes aux militants et
que ce soit chez génération z ou même
chez déchets des gens beaucoup plus âgée
enfin vous dire de nos âges respectifs
sur sur ce plateau
mais monsieur benedetti dans la même
tranche d'âge que nous évidemment ce
sont des gens qui n'avaient jamais
milité pour beaucoup mais moi ça braille
est donc annoncée à chirac ah non ça me
fait ch emmanuel macron c'est tout à
fait la face cachée de la lune d'or dans
la discipline dit c'est l'argent de la
différence c'est que c'est que pas de
parti en cr x et y sorti de nulle part
sa vie ressemble une ferveur de taille
rassemble sauf que l'on met du fonds
chinois li c'était quelqu'un qui a la
partie d'hier et visionner ma carrière
politique c'est ça n'aurait chantal
gendre idéal mais en tout cas il va
passer sa vie s'est senti c'est
l'antithèse c'est la némésis des
venelles macron celui mais par contre
toute la dynamique que ce soit sur le
financement de la campagne que ce soit
sur l'amour des médias qui lui que lui
portent les médias j'ai en face de mes
yeux en tant qu analyste politique à peu
près les mêmes ressorts que ce qui a été
derrière et moulin de macron en 2010
elle est en plus pour les politiquement
ils sont assez d'accord au niveau
économique sur le fait qu'il va falloir
allonger l'âge de la retraite que de
toute façon peut pas augmenter les
salaires qu'il va falloir faire un plan
d'austérité à partir de windows tout ça
non non non là c'est non alors ton par
gc pardonnez-moi pasqua il faut pas
exclure
qu'il faut reprendre monsieur poulin
près de trois mois ces jeunes étaient
vivement se succéder sur les plateaux
les ami d'eric zemmour qui sont parfois
très très jeune ça vous évoque quoi ça
peut peut-être ce soir et que je suis
assez d'accord avec alexis poulat sur
les ressorts en tout cas de la
communication il y a des similarités
entre la façon dont aujourd'hui se
construit la campagne ou la pré campagne
d'eric zemmour et la façon dont la
campagne de emmanuel macron son ton
s'est elle aussi construite c'est à dire
en effet eu une très grande attention
médiatique
l'arrivée 2 en effet deux de gens qui
pour la plupart n'ont parfois jamais eu
d'engagement politique où on va mais
milite et donc là aussi il ya aussi cela
avec néanmoins quand même une différence
me semble-t-il c'est que emmanuel manuel
louis emmanuel macron pardon pouvait se
prévaloir du renfort d'un certain nombre
de leaders d'opinion ou
notamment de grands élus qui d'emblée
l'ont suivi je pense à gérard collomb à
l'époque aux maires d'autres de
montpellier de ce point de vue quand
même eric zemmour pour l'instant
il me paraît être démuni que ne l'était
emmanuel macro à l'époque même s'il y
avait une explication simple là c'est
assez identique or il ya une explication
simple arnaud tout simplement c'est
parce qu'il n'a jamais fait de politique
intra muros si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
il n'a jamais été membre d'un cabinet
ministériel il n'a jamais errer sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale donc
évidemment il ya des accointances qui
sont moins visibles pour autant ça fait
30 ans qu'il travaille aux côtés de la
classe politique en étant journaliste
je suis persuadé je n'ai pas de boule de
cristal ni de scoop à vous donner mais
il est évident que lorsque des instituts
de sondage donnent eric zemmour à 17% je
peux vous assurer que chez les
républicains on le regarde avec beaucoup
plus de respect qu'il ya trois jours
donc il est fort à parier que ces
soutiens plutôt discret pour l'instant
et je j'aime bien parler de tous ces
grands ténors des républicains qui
brillent par leur absence de commentaire
sur le congrès à laurent wauquiez qui
quand même va peser lourd si jamais ils
annoncent un ralliement à eric zemmour
va écouter chaque chose en son temps
voilà chaque chose en son temps mais je
vous à nous appeler une chose c'est que
aussi en défense eric zemmour c'est que
lui utilise pas l'argent public pour
faire sa pré campagne parce qu'il mêle
macron alors qu'il était à bercy
utiliser les frais de bouche du
ministère pour faire des déjeuners et
des dîners vous différents magazines qui
font leur combien nous a coûté ces trois
jours à marseille j'aimerais bien savoir
et puis avant ça
l'allergie est volé pour mener à bien
sûr un petit modèle fin peut-être sauvé
dating où le petit mot défend vous
entendez
winner le petit mot de la fin c'est que
en fin de compte aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation je crois qu'il faut quand
même rester très prudent moi c'est ce
que je pense qu'en effet il ya une
dynamique qu'il faut regarder de près
qui règle et nous on va une un potentiel
qui est aujourd'hui non négligeable sur
l'ensemble des droits de française mais
qu' il faut rappeler qu on est à six
mois d'élections que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les sondages ne font pas
l'élection de les estimations font fait
il faut le rappeler aussi pour un
certain nombre de sondages sur ceux qui
sont sûrs d'aller voter et qui sait et
qui nous disent qu'ils sont sûrs d'aller
voter donc relativiser l'état de ces
sondages aux croyants soyons prudent je
pense c'est ce qui me paraît en tout cas
là la principale leçon qu'il faut tirer
de cette séquence effectivement merci à
nos benedetti avec six poules à benjamin
cauchy mais je serais vous d'avoir été
en direct avec nous ce soir et la
campagne la campagne présidentielle qui
se joue beaucoup en provence en ce
moment emmanuel macron pas encore en
lice est officiellement candidat à sa
réélection lui non plus a choisi
montpellier pour ouvrir demain sa
nouvelle formule du sommet afrique
france le président qui a choisi de
l'inviter aucun ses homologues africains
entre montpellier samantha hammami notre
envoyé spécial pour le sommet bonsoir
samantha alors le sommet france-afrique
tente de se renouveler c'est bien ça
bonsoir stéphanie alors vous faites bien
de dire tente de se renouveler vous
n'êtes pas dupe en tout cas ce qui se
renouvelle ses cartes et france n'est
toujours pas accréditer lorsque emmanuel
macron l'initient à un rendez vous au
moment où je vous parle nous ne sommes
pas accrédités pour couvrir ce sommet ce
nouveau sommet afrique france demain
nous nous rendrons sur place au sud
arena et nous vous tiendrons au courant
en tous les cas dans l'entourage de la
présidence et au niveau même des manuels
macron l'assurent il s'agit de se parler
sans tabou donc c'est vrai un format
inédit un nouveau sommet afrique-france
la sémantique là elle est importante on
insiste beaucoup sur le terme nouveau
alors c'est vrai c'est une première il
n'y a aucun chef d'état invité demain
donc place à la société civile et à la
jeunesse on annonce la participation de
3000 personnes dont un millier de jeunes
350 entrepreneurs si nous ne sommes pas
accréditée en tout cas nous avons bien
reçu le programme je vous l'assuré je lé
bien ce côté ça me semble quand même un
petit peu trop chargé pour une seule
journée il ya beaucoup de conférences
des conférences à économique culturel
scientifique sportive même comme si
finalement on pouvait concentrer le
meilleur de l'afrique en une journée
donc voilà pour la forme reste à savoir
si cela va réellement impacté les
fondements de la relation afrique-france
beaucoup en doutent d'ailleurs en
parallèle se déroule ici à montpellier
un contre sommet sur plusieurs jours à
l'initiative d'un collectif
d'associations on y retrouve
l'association attac de lutte contre la
corruption les ong survie des collègues
des collectifs panafricain des
collectifs de défense des sans-papiers
l'objectif c'est de dénoncer les maux de
la françafrique de dénoncer la
continuité de la politique française sur
le continent africain sur les plans
économique monétaire avec une réforme du
franc cfa à qui piétine et sur le plan
aussi migratoires sachez stéphanie qu'on
a appris aujourd'hui via un communiqué
de ce collectif du contre sommet que des
militants en faveur des sans papiers ont
été arrêtés à la gare de montpellier à
la descente
de leurs trains en provenance de paris
sciences et samantha quels sont les
enjeux de ce nouveau sommet afrique
france justement
alors stéphanie l'enjeu pour emmanuel
macron assez bien évidemment de réussir
son pari dans un contexte délicat de
tension avec le mali mais surtout
l'algérie un pari loin d'être gagné
sur ces fronts diplomatiques
le message qu emmanuel macron va
adresser à la société civile à la
jeunesse le discours qu'il qu'il fera
demain et d'un risque en réalité
d'aggraver un peu plus ces crises franco
malienne et et franco algérienne et puis
aussi il y a un problème de crédibilité
si emmanuel macron dissocier les
sociétés à civile des chefs d'état
africains des pouvoirs africains en
réalité il n'en est rien parce qu'en mai
dernier emmanuel macron il a bien convié
tous ses homologues africains à une
grande messe et c'était le sommet sur le
financement en grande pompe il a convié
les homologues africains du pré carré
français mais aussi en dehors de ce pré
carré et c'est vrai que ça ressemblait à
un petit peu un sommet finalement
afrique france et puis demain autre
exemple demain on attend une délégation
tchadienne il y aura certainement des
activistes à des opposants eh bien on se
souvient encore que emmanuel macron il
n'avait pas hésité à se déplacer pour
assister aux obsèques d'idriss déby au
tchad idriss deby qui est très content
et qui était très contesté par la
population tchadienne pour sa longévité
au pouvoir on sait que le tchad c'est un
allié stratégique effectivement dans la
lutte antiterroriste mais c'est surtout
un allié stratégique de la france alors
vous le voyez du coup emmanuel macron il
tente effectivement ce pari et puis
il ya aussi on se souvient son discours
devant la jeunesse africaine à
ouagadougou et finalement depuis le
discours de la baule de françois
hollande sur fond d'effondrement de la
chute de de l'union soviétique à son
discours à lui et bien rien n'a vraiment
changé puisque il s'agit à chaque fois
de promettre de changer de paradigme
pour une relation afrique-france d'égal
à égal mais en réalité il n'en est rien
alors emmanuel macron qu'est ce qu'il
fait eh bien il a fait appel aux
services
du politologue et historien
camerounais achille mbembe qui a une
aura internationale
l'enjeu pour emmanuel macron
effectivement lorsqu il s'entoure de ce
genre de personnalité il n'est pas le
seul et bien c'est de séduire les pays
anglophones du continent africain qui
n'ont pas vraiment besoin de la france
pour
avancer alors achille mbembe vous savez
il a fondé les sanaa panafricaniste il a
fondé les ateliers de la pensée à dakar
avec pour slogan oublions la france eh
bien il a rendu il ya quelques jours son
rapport à emmanuel macron pour cela il a
mené des consultations dans une dizaine
de pays au total 140 pages avec treize
propositions et finalement des
propositions qui sont dans la lignée des
précédents rapports que l'on connaît le
rapport sarr sa voix sur la restauration
du patrimoine africain ou encore le
rapport de benjamin stora sur les
mémoires de la colonisation et de la
guerre d'algérie donc voilà stéphanie
pas certaine en finale que tout cela
toute cette grand'messe change
réellement la donne merci beaucoup
samantha ramsamy en direct de
montpellier alors justement comment est
perçu ce sommet nouvelle formule en
l'absence donc un des présidents
africains en habit pour la première fois
depuis 50 ans depuis le continent
éléments de réponse avec notre reporter
abidjan lille a fait à nouveau un énième
sommet une opération de communication de
la pure cosmétique
voici quelques qualificatifs entendu ici
à propos de ce sommet afrique-france ces
étudiants ivoiriens que nous avons
rencontré déplore que l'avenir politique
économique et même militaire semble
bonjour se discuter en france et surtout
il reste très sceptique quant à la
volonté du président français de
dépoussiérer les relations franco
africaines le problème des africains
doit se régler par les africains la
france ne pourra jamais jamais réglé le
problème d afrique quand tu as un mal
j'étais débrouillard aigle sur mal toi
sur la france ne viendra que pour ses
intérêts quand il ya problème ici nous
devons réticents ici ouais de notre pays
si on ferme la porte complètement
peut-être on n'est pas en quoi mes yeux
de faire les choses de nous mêmes voilà
on s'affronte réalise aussi je suis
ivoirien je suis africaine moi j'ai
moins qu'on soit autonome à 100 tout
simplement je constate que c'est
peut-être le cas pour ces mois donc on
est encore en phase de développement va
braver les étapes tout doucement on peut
pas faire peut-être un voies de fait là
ça va être le déclic quand il s'agit de
c'est un litige
politique d'alain eux les intérêts sont
toujours présents en diodes et ça
l'est théorise pas raison nous avons
assisté à plusieurs scènes si les amants
akaffou loup voilà où les dieux sont
venus et a71 gens de la mairie voir link
ont perdu la vie l'avoir tandis que
l'armée française est sur le sol vanille
intervention militaire francs cfa
ingérence cette jeunesse dresse un bilan
assez négatif des relations entre la
france et l'afrique jusqu'à présent
depuis que moi je suis né depuis je
commence à apprendre quoi se défaire
politique et août j'ai pas vu
la nécessité de l' inde et a fait
française dans la petite quand on
regarde les différents sites miniers de
la côte d'ivoire on voit que il y a plus
être aussi dans taux qui dirige la tête
de ce petit minet en côte d'ivoire tout
en les étudiant es afrique et au bien
désolé les professeurs dans les
universités ont la capacité d'investir
et de diriger sa solitude me niel il
serait bien que l'afrique où la côte
d'ivoire se fondent
où j'ai même créé voilà créer quelque
chose de nouveau la patiente a elle
aussi prolifique quelle est la vision
politique typiquement arcade typiquement
ivoirienne vous l'avez entendu de
nombreuses critiques à l'encontre de la
france est le pari des manuels mâcon
elle va s'avérer difficile à relever
pour cette jeunesse ivoirienne il s'agit
avant tout d'établir une relation plus
équilibrée avec la france et surtout un
partenariat gagnant gagnant en
particulier dans le secteur économique
est au centre du contre sommet
france-afrique ce week-end la politique
migratoire du gouvernement également
l'exécutif critiqué pour sa gestion des
migrants aussi dans un rapport de
lohengrin rights watch l'enquète mettant
en cause les pratiques des autorités
françaises dans le camp de réfugiés de
calais ses alentours dans le nord de la
france des explications en images
[Musique]
quand la police arrive nous avons cinq
minutes pour sortir de la tante avant
qu'elle ne détruise tout mais ce n'est
pas possible pour cinq personnes dont
deux jeunes enfants de s'habiller en
cinq minutes dans une tente
[Musique]
du
la consigne que j'ai donnés pour éviter
de revivre ce que les calaisiens ont
connu il ya quelques années c'est la
fermeté des forces de l'ordre qui se
traduit par des opérations toutes les 24
ou 48 heures
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre henry président de france
paternité bonsoy pierre-henri merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
humiliation harcèlement quotidien des
migrants à calais c'est l entoure on
vient d'entendre les ong human rights
watch qui pointe du doigt directement
l'état votre réaction sur ces
accusations
écoutez une
situation est parfaitement documenté et
depuis longtemps a calé en l'occurrence
nous savons que depuis
2016 il y a environ un millier de
personnes qui se concentre sur le
littoral calaisien mais qui cherche à
rejoindre à toutes fins la grande
bretagne et depuis cette date oui nous
savons qu'il y à des opérations de
répéter des forces de l'ordre et qui
parfois souvent se transforme en
violence est ce que l'on peut qualifier
de violence le fait de les serrer des
tentes alors qu'il fait très froid est
ce que l'on peut qualifier de violence
le fait d'être harcelés alors que l'on
manque que de tout le travail des forces
de l'ordre est un travail extrêmement
complexe ce que les autorités françaises
leur demande de faire a calé et d'une
certaine manière elle c'est absurde je
rappelle que la grande bretagne ait
adopté le rexy tu es sortie de l'union
européenne en promettant à ses la
population qu'il n'y aurait plus de
migration
la grande-bretagne or il n'en est rien
plus vous renforcer
les contrôles plus vous fermer la route
migratoire et plus vous fait courir des
risques aux personnes qui veulent
emprunter ce sont des milliers de
personnes qui depuis le début de l'année
en tenter le passage de la manche pour
aller vers la grande bretagne
donc je pense qu'il faut sortir de cette
situation est évidemment à inventer
autre chose
sortons pierre ory vous qu'il
connaissait bien le sujet comment on en
sort mais on en sort en essayant de
construire une voie de migration légale
notamment pour les membres de famille
ou encore pour les mineurs qui sont
nombreux a calé je rappelle que c'est ce
qui avait été tentée en
2016 2017 il y avait vu un amendement
qui a été adopté
par le législateurs britanniques qui
permettait de faire en sorte que les
gens puissent rejoindre légalement la
grande bretagne a pas d'autre solution
parce que là on est dans une impasse
totale la grande-bretagne paye la france
pour que
nous empêchions les personnes de
rejoindre
les pays
l'angleterre l'irlande etc donc ça c'est
pas possible on peut pas continuer
de cette manière et il faut sortir de
cette situation ou encore une fois le
nombre le les flux sont relativement bas
un millier de personnes mais continue et
donc il y à un certain nombre de gens
qui sont à calais qui ont vocation à
demander l'asile en grande bretagne et
je m'étonne moi des déclarations du
gouvernement britannique
quand il explique que par exemple il va
accueillir vingt mille réfugiés en
provenance d'afghanistan mais vous savez
vous avez un certain nombre de gens qui
sont à calais qui sont afghans et qui
veulent rejoindre la grande-bretagne
commençons par là aujourd'hui clairement
là la grande bretagne ne prend pas sa
part c'est ce que vous dit en substance
il faut les exhorter voir les
contraintes peut-être à apprendre cette
ville d'aba il faut absolument d'abord
c'est un énorme mensonge
que
le bric site le bric site n'a rien
empêché du tout et tous ceux qui prônent
les allemands pour empêcher la migration
se trompe il faut évidemment demandé à
la grande bretagne une approche beaucoup
plus
pragmatique beaucoup plus humaine et
puis ici éviter que les forces de police
fait son travail mais évidemment absurde
merci beaucoup pierre henry président de
france terre n'était d'avoir été avec
nerd ou de m'avoir invité on dirait que
je vous en prie en direct sur rtl france
c'était il ya vingt ans jour pour jour
l'invasion de l'afghanistan par les
états unis une offensive lancée par
george deubeuliou mouche en réponse aux
attaques du 11 septembre
en quelques semaines la coalition
internationale dirigée par washington à
renverser le gouvernement taliban basé à
kaboul les talibans ont qui ont repris
le pouvoir le 15 août dernier après le
retrait des forces américaines écouter
ces quelques réactions à kaboul la
capitale
les etats-unis ont leurs propres
objectifs au cours des vingt dernières
années des gens ont été tués notre
économie a empiré maintenant nous sommes
même sanctionné par les états unis
le gouvernement américain n'est pas venu
ici pour aider notre peuple ils sont
venus ici pour leurs propres intérêts
les etats unis nous ont rien apporté de
bon mais nous ont seulement laissé avec
une guerre civile
après cette prise de pouvoir des
talibans les pourparlers internationaux
seront organisées le 20 octobre prochain
moscou les talibans qui prendront part à
ces discussions leurs promesses sont
scrutés de près par la communauté
internationale depuis le retrait
américain et pour tenter de prouver leur
bonne foi ces derniers ouvrent leurs
services de passeport à kaboul farah
milk
une scène chaotique
elle rappelle celle qui s'est déroulé à
l'aéroport de kaboul il ya quelques
semaines ce mercredi le bureau des
passeports de la capitale a été pris
d'assaut par une centaine d'afghans
seulement un jour après l'annnonce de sa
réouverture
tous les employés de la direction des
passeports qu'ils soient hommes ou
femmes sont de retour au travail
la majorité des gens qui viennent ici
pour demander un passeport n'auront pas
de mauvaise surprise ce sont en majorité
des gens qui attendent déjà depuis un
mois ou plus qui ont des soucis ou une
maladie qui doit être soigné à
l'étranger
fermé depuis le départ des forces
américaines newt le bureau des
passeports de kaboul reprendra son
activité dès samedi d'après les
autorités talibane cité par reuters
une nouvelle que les insurgés peinent à
partager avec les afghans déçu de ne pas
voir leurs demandes traitées
immédiatement
vous pouvez voir à quel point la
situation est floue en ce moment ne nous
attendions à ce que le bureau ouvre
aujourd'hui mais il n'y a pas
d'informations et nous ne savons pas
quand ils donneront l'ordre de traiter
nos demandes de passeport il n'y a
personne pour nous guider sur ce qu'il
faut faire selon les autorités le
service sera en mesure de délivrer 6000
passeport par jour pour faire face à
l'importante demande de la population
une annonce semblable à une lueur
d'espoir pour de nombreux afghans
n'ayant pas eu la possibilité de quitter
le territoire lors d exfiltration
américaines en août dernier
j'ai l'intention d'aller aux états unis
comme j'ai travaillé pour eux peut-être
que je peux avoir le privilège d'y aller
des autorisations de sortie du
territoire distribué comparable à un
test de la bonne foi des talibans mi
septembre les insurgés avaient
publiquement assuré qu'il les traite ou
leurs compatriotes quitter l'afghanistan
à condition qu'ils disposent de
documents valides une promesse à tenir
condition sinequanone pour que lés
talibans puissent accéder aux
financements internationaux
indispensables pour redresser l'économie
nationale en chute libre depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des insurgés
et outre atlantique après le fiasco de
ce retrait précipité des troupes
américaines de nombreuses voix au sein
de l'armée réclame la nécessité de tirer
les leçons ces vingt années de guerre on
en parle avec notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
depuis plus d'un mois maintenant on voit
se succéder des hauts responsables du
pentagone qui affirme vouloir étudier
ces vingt années donc de guerre pour en
tirer les conclusions qui s'imposent
oui c'est vrai on a pu suivre beaucoup
d'auditions devant le congrès américain
on a pu voir par exemple anthony blinken
mais aussi les plus hauts gradés du
pentagone avec cette interrogation
comment expliquer ce fiasco lors du
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan beaucoup de critiques sur
le manque d'anticipation et aussi une
polémique sur le fait que des
conseillers militaires des généraux en
l'occurrence ont averti les forces les
autorités politiques sur les risques
d'un retrait si soudain à des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan écouté par
exemple le chef d'état-major des armées
ici aux etats unis c'était il ya
quelques jours à l'automne 2020 mon
analyse était qu un retrait accéléré
sans remplir des conditions spécifiques
et nécessaire qui risquait de faire
perdre le gains substantiels réalisés en
afghanistan nuire est potentiellement à
la crédibilité mondiale des etats-unis
et pourrait précipiter un effondrement
général des forces de sécurité afghanes
et du gouvernement afghan entraînant une
prise de pouvoir complète par les
talibans ou une guerre civile générale
alors le général marc mulet que vous
venez d'entendre affirme aussi que cet
échec stratégique est en fait le
résultat de fait a cumulé pendant 20 ans
12,7 à deuxième interrogation est ce que
finalement cette guerre en afghanistan
en valait la peine surtout au vu des
résultats et bien à cette question karl
eikenberry répond non lui qui a commandé
des forces en afghanistan avant même de
devenir l'ambassadeur américain en
afghanistan pendant deux ans et puis
d'autres gradés de l'armée américaine
admettent aujourd'hui que des erreurs
ont commencé dès le début de la guerre
avec une méconnaissance de
l'environnement mes connaissances à des
enjeux et puis plus généralement un
manque de vision à moyen long terme sur
la situation sur place il faut aussi
rappeler qu'en 2019 le washington post
avait publié ce qu'ils avaient appelé
les afghanistan and paper's des
documents jusque là jamais dévoilées et
où le public a pu en fait découvrir que
les autorités américaines à savait
pertinemment et depuis longtemps que
cette guerre en afghanistan était un
gagnable contrairement à ce qu'elle
affirmait pourtant publiquement pendant
toutes ces années et thomas parmi les
critiques 1 que l'on entend autour de ce
conflit il ya évidemment le coût
financier de cette guerre pour un
résultat évidemment on à dire incontesté
absolument parce que si la pertinence de
cette guerre en afghanistan est remise
en question c'est en grande partie parce
qu'elle a été un véritable gouffre
financier pour les états unis on estime
aujourd'hui à plus de 2000 milliards de
dollars le coût total de la guerre en
afghanistan avec aussi à des dépenses
qui se sont avérées inutiles il ya
l'exemple de cet hôtel qui a été
construit à kaboul pour 85 millions de
dollars et qui n'a finalement jamais
ouvert ces portes ou encore une base
militaire américaine construite dans le
désert pour 36 millions de dollars et
qui elle non plus n'a jamais servi il ya
aussi eu des dépenses notamment pour
lutter contre le trafic d'opium en
afghanistan pour un résultat là aussi
plus que mitigés alors le montant total
de cette guerre est en plus encore en
train d'augmenter puisque il y a les
intérêts de la dette qui a été
contractée pour financer cette guerre en
afghanistan si bien et bien que le
remboursement de ces intérêts devraient
durer au moins jusqu'à 2050 mais
évidemment le plus dramatique reste le
bilan humain on rappelle qu'il y à 2500
soldats américains qui sont morts en
afghanistan 4000 civils américains qui
ont également été tués dans le pays et
puis il ne faut pas oublier les dizaines
de milliers de civils afghans qui ont
eux aussi perdu la vie pendant ces vingt
années de guerre alors pour finir on dit
souvent que l'opinion américaine est
largement favorable à la fin de cette
guerre en afghanistan ce qui est vrai
mais c'est quand même à nuancer avec les
récents événements qui se sont produits
notamment cet été il ya un sondage qui
est paru cette semaine aux états unis
qui affirme que 28 % des américains
interrogés soutiennent le retrait total
des troupes et que finalement 50%
d'entre eux auraient préféré que les
autorités laissent au moins une partie
des soldats sur place merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington
en pleine crise mondiale de l'énergie la
file de saint pétersbourg et accueille
aujourd'hui un forum gazier plusieurs
responsables internationaux sont
présents l'un des enjeux de ces échanges
l'avenir du marché
les premières discussions se sont
achevées tout à leur compte rendu de
notre correspondant sur place en russie
antoine clair durant la session plénière
plusieurs hauts responsables de grands
groupes gaziers internationaux ont tour
à tour pris la parole la représentante
de gazprom ainsi souligné l'importance
des investissements sur le long terme
mais aussi l'importance de conserver la
confiance des investisseurs et à ce
titre à la regrettée la financiarisation
des marchés énergétiques qui implique de
la vision à court terme et de
l'instabilité nord - elle a salué la
réaction des marchés à la suite de
l'intervention de vladimir poutine de
mercredi
nous avons constaté qu'après la réunion
tenue hier par le président russe et
après les déclarations qui ont été
faites les tarifs du gaz ont chuté de
façon spectaculaire et nous avons poussé
un soupir de soulagement en disant dieu
merci
la situation en ukraine qui voit de
moins en moins de gaz transiter via son
territoire a elle aussi été évoquée sur
ce point la profession s'accorde à dire
que le pays fournisseurs choisis le
chemin qu'il désire pour acheminer son
gaz
c'est à nos partenaires russes de
choisir l'itinéraire
nous espérons que gazprom pourra bientôt
passer par un autre itinéraire pour
exporter du gaz vers l'europe et pas
seulement vers l'allemagne
c'est leur décision qu'ils choisissent
un itinéraire passant par l'ukraine un
itinéraire passant par la pologne ou
celui du nord stream ou tout autre
itinéraire disponibles je pense qu'il
est positif de constater qu'il y a
manifestement un impact que nous pouvons
heureusement déjà voir l'achèvement de
l'infrastructure supplémentaire
d'exportations de gaz vers l'europe aura
un impact également sur les prix du gaz
et c'est une leçon fondamentale que nous
avons tirée du projet nord stream 2 la
balle revient donc à gazprom en ce qui
concerne le choix de l'itinéraire
de nombreux autres aspects ont été
abordés comme par exemple la transition
énergétique vers des énergies moins
émettrice de co2 à ce titre il a
beaucoup été question de l'hydrogène
lors de cette session plénière et
l'ensemble de la profession est au
diapason sur le constat suivant gaz et
pétrole reste incontournable à court
terme et rester avec nous dans quelques
instants au parlement de la crise du
kobe 19 ans et il n'y aura pas des
logements du pad sanitaire avant le 15
novembre c'est ce qu'a annoncé le porte
parole du gouvernement aujourd'hui et
puis direction l'espagne où les
discothèques ou n'ouvre en catalogne a
plus d'un an de fermeture presque
ininterrompue
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terrorisme est-ce que vous
êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon ce avec les talibans
étaient en train de revenir sur le
terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui a
été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda est taliban ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre
devoir moral que de venir en aide à ce
peuple qui a souffert tant par le passé
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
pro de sécurité mettre en danger nos
libertés
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative entendu qu il est clair
que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie d'avoir
un huitième
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste du
melon dégringolade de notre posture à la
fois stratégiques politiques sur la
scène internationale et industriels
aussi les pays européens sont ils perçus
comme des pourvoyeurs de troupes de
supplétifs au service des états unis ou
bien des alliés et de véritables
partenaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire les crises ducobu 19 en france
il n'y aura pas des logements du passé
ni té avant le 15 novembre
c'est ce qu'annonce ne pas parle du
gouvernement pour gabriela thaler
d'élever des contraintes n'est pas venu
mais les tests de dépistage dits de
confort eux deviendront bien payant le
15 octobre il faudra débourser 44 euros
pour un pcr 22 euros au moins pour un an
petits génies qu elle sa bonne stratégie
alors que l'épidémie marque le pas
décryptage dans quelques instants avec
un invité
[Musique]
4615 cap de caux vide sur les dernières
24 heures en france la décrue des
derniers jours se confirme et pourtant
l'heure de levée des contraintes n'est
pas venu pour autant le message du porte
parole du gouvernement est claire après
le conseil de défense sanitaire et les
conseils des ministres dans le même
temps les tests de dépistage dits de
confort deviendront payants dans une
semaine comme convenu les précisions de
nicholas pettit
c'est une première depuis le mois de
juillet en france le taux d'incidence
est passé sous le seuil des 50 pour cent
mille habitants cette circulation du
virus moins importante à l'échelle
nationale se traduira lundi par la levée
de l'obligation du port du masque à
l'école dans deux nouveaux départements
pour la levée éventuelle du passani
terre en revanche il faudra encore
patienter
l'heure de lever toutes les mesures
toutes les contraintes n'est pas venu
dans près d'une trentaine de
départements à l'épidémie ne recule plus
nous sommes tombés à un niveau très bas
mais ils ne reculent plus voir repart
très légèrement à la hausse sans nous
alerter outre mesure à ce stade
plusieurs situation interpelle notamment
dans plusieurs départements de la région
pays de loire ou encore dans le
département de l'aude notre vigilance
doit rester total nous savons que le
virus m l'hiver et que le froid arrive
si durant la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement n'a pas toujours suivi ces
avis le conseil scientifique et son
appel à la prudence sont cette fois
suivis d'effets le porte parole du
gouvernement a d'ailleurs prévenu qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'adaptation du passani
terre avant le 15 membre également suivi
par le gouvernement l'avis de la haute
autorité de santé qui mercredi a donné
son aval pour une 3e injection aux
soignants dès aujourd'hui donc les
soignants qui sont complètement vaccinés
qui avait un schéma vaccinal complet
depuis plus de six mois peuvent recourir
au rappel vaccinal nous les invitons
évidemment à le faire ils sont
d'ailleurs très nombreuses ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines à avoir
émis le souhait de pouvoir recourir au
rappel dès aujourd'hui ceux qui sont
éligibles qui sont concernés peuvent
prendre rendez vous depuis le début du
mois et l'ouverture de la campagne de
rappel aux plus de 65 ans et aux
personnes présentant des comorbidités
environ un million cinq cent mille
français ont reçu cette troisième dose
une troisième injection qui d'après la
haute autorité de santé deviendra
nécessaire au cours des mois qui
viennent pour l'ensemble de la
population
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
françois blanchecotte président du
syndicat des biologistes bon soir
françois blanchecotte merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france 1 l'une des
informations on en parlait il ya
quelques instants de la journée le pape
sanitaire qui qui finalement se
poursuivra jusqu'en novembre pour vous
c'est la bonne stratégie alors que
clairement l'épidémie marque le pas en
france
oui l'épidémie marque le pas mais en
même temps on va prendre une décision
aussi de plus rembourser les tests et
donc on va avoir moins de français qui
sont non vaccinés qui viendront dans nos
laboratoires donc il faut quand même
garder un oeil sur ce qui va se passer
au niveau de l'épidémie et donc de
continuer à faire le pas cet hiver s'est
d'emblée une sécurité et puis en fait la
politique du gouvernement pour
abandonner le remboursement des tests et
de favoriser ou d'orienter les français
pour la vaccination
donc on voit qu'on va dans le même sens
pour l'instant c'est plus une mesure de
prudence aurait effectivement c'est est
un 10-2 de confort on se demande
toujours comment cet adjectif été choisi
pour ce genre de test pardonnez moi ce
trait d'humour mais effectivement
44 euros pour un pc à 22 euros pour un
test antigénique des scientifiques ont
critiqué aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette
décision parlant même d'aberrations
votre point de vue vous de biologistes
alors il est vrai qu'avec la gratuité
nous avions un système de surveillance
au jour le jour quasiment en photo pour
la rue id instantanée nous savions tous
les jours le nombre de positif comment
évoluer sur les territoires la
circulation du virus on va être avec
cette mesure un peu plus aveugle c'est
certain on va certainement avoir des
éléments qui vont nous échapper alors
dans le même temps on va essayer aussi
de contrôler les écoles les primaires
l'écho de façon à savoir un petit peu
comment le virgule le virus à circuler
quand on va arrêter le le port du masque
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même des
mesures
barrières pour essayer de voir un petit
peu comment on peut juguler avoir une
idée de ce qui se passe pour vous cela
va marquer justement à une hausse de
l'épidémie le fait de ne plus testé tout
le monde ou au contraire peut-être une
baisse qui n'en est pas une parce qu'on
n'aura pas les chiffres
ça peut être toutes les hypothèses on
sait pas vraiment d'abord combien on va
faire de tests on sait pas ce qui va se
passer à partir du 15 pour l'instant
nous avions continué à descendre mais
toujours avec un nombre très élevé
puisque la dernière semaine nous avions
2,1 millions de tests avec toujours un
peu de 2 millions de pc r par semaine
donc on voit que les pcr ne baissez pas
forcément c'est plutôt les tests
antigénique qu'icbc maintenant on va se
rendre compte voir si les gens viennent
quand même se faire dépister je rappelle
quand même pour tous les français que
quand on a des symptômes même si on
n'est pas vacciné qu'on a une ordonnance
on est quand même pris en charge donc
normalement les gens qui ont des
symptômes de qui pourrait penser à l'aco
vide ils ont quand même une prise en
charge alors clairement cette nouvelle
mesure on vous l'avait dit un le
gouvernement espère inciter et augmenter
la couverture vaccinale
c'est la vaccination à marche forcée
pour vous plus tôt
une bonne chose finalement
écoutez moi je fais partie des gens et
des professions de santé qui sont
matinée très tôt cette année à partir de
début janvier on était convaincus quand
même que c'était un peu le seul moyen de
sortir de cette torpeur que nous avions
et des mesures barrières qui était
contraignante on le voit aujourd'hui que
les français supporte de moins en moins
quand même le mas qu'ils auront envie de
retrouver un espace de liberté et c'est
vrai que cette vaccination nous donne
cette opportunité
maintenant je pense qu aura toujours une
frange de français qui seront
irréductibles par contre on peut encore
convaincre à mon avis un certain nombre
de français surtout à l'aube de l'hiver
de ce refroidissement de la venue du
vinyle du virus grippal donc je pense
qu'il ya il ya quand même une
possibilité que ça se fasse
le gouvernement aujourd'hui un qui
autorise encore ce n'est pas obligatoire
mais qui autorise cette fameuse
troisième dose pour les personnels
soignants dont vous faites partie
commence est accueilli dans le monde et
des soignants parce qu'on sait que là
aussi il ya eu quelques récalcitrants
mais pas la troisième dose est ce
qu'elle est aussi bien accueillie que
les deux premières quand même écouter ça
commence seulement on a vu la décision
européenne qui a validé un petit peu ce
schéma on a vu la décision française qui
l'a qu'il a entériné pour l'instant pour
une partie de la population que sont les
soignants il ya encore évidemment des
résistances ici ou là ne soyons qui
veulent pas se faire vacciner je pense
que en tout cas nous nous sommes
convaincus que si les nécessités de voir
ce rappel si on a des taux effectivement
qu'ils peuvent descendre au niveau de la
protection qu'elle est justifiée et
qu'elle a qu'à vraiment besoin de la
voir avant l'arrivée de l'hiver pour
revenir sur les tests un payant ce sera
ma dernière question il ya peut-être
aussi quelques contraintes budgétaires
dans cette décision ça heureusement
vous l'avez compris bien sûr le le père
fss 2021 et un peu explosé les tests ont
été extrêmement important et en très
grand nombre à partir de l'annnonce du
pass sanitaires obligatoires
on a vu qu'on a passé
largement la fourchette des 4 5 millions
de tests par semaine avec souvent une
grande partie de tests antigénique et
donc c'est ce correctif qui arrive on
retrouve un peu une situation qu'on a
connu en juin 2020 avant que les tests
soient gratuits donc on repasse sur un
circuit vraiment de symptômes 2 cas
contacts on retrouve en fait la
philosophie que nous avions avant et je
pense que pour la plupart des régions
c'est nécessaire c'est suffisant par
contre il faut être vraiment attentif si
ça redémarre s'il ya des clusters qui
débute il faut absolument qu'on les
explore et qu'on ait pu identifier
toutes les personnes qui pourraient être
positives merci beaucoup à françois
blanchet de la banque était avec nous en
direct sur rt france
et tout le corps hospitalier qui est
tabou avec la crise sanitaire en est
sèche femmes se sont mobilisés encore
aujourd'hui sixième journée d'action
depuis le début de l'année est rythmée
par une grève et des manifestations
les sages femmes qui demandent une
revalorisation de leur salaire une
reconnaissance de leur statut médical et
une hausse des effectifs une marche
notamment à paris suivie par notre
reporter david kelly fin elles étaient
environ assimile à défiler dans les rues
cet après midi de la gare montparnasse
jusqu'ici au ministère de la santé 6000
un chiffre assez conséquent puisque en
france on dénombre pas moins de 23 mille
sage femme un chiffre qui représente en
tout cas la colère de ces sages femmes
lessive est épuisée elle réclame
plusieurs choses d'abord une
revalorisation de leurs salaires mais
est surtout elles ciblent un manque de
reconnaissance de la profession dans le
monde à médicale dans le viseur olivier
ferrand et sont à ségur de la santé à
cette concertation imaginer au mois de
mars est 2020 avait totalement mis de
côté les sages-femmes après plusieurs
mois de mobilisation elle avait obtenu
gain de cause et une revalorisation
salariale de 183 euros un net par mois
mais cette augmentation de salaire n'est
pas suffisante pour la plupart des
syndicats à écouter
nous on a mille deux cents heures de
formation en plus comparé à des
formations de dentaire ou de pharmacien
c'est à dire que nous en cinq ans on
fait l'équivalent de leur formation en
six ans pour imager c'est comme si vous
aviez une valise que vous partiez en
voyage à la basse peut-être en 2009 vous
arriviez à fermer cette valise à partir
en voyage depuis les compétences sont
accumulés mais la formation ne sait pas
ne s'est pas réformé bah du coup on
adéquation du coup vous allez rajouter
des vêtements dans votre valise n'arrive
pas réussir à la ferme et du coup ça a
créé des burn out ça crée des
réorientations sacré du mal-être
étudiants il ya des réponses qui sont
apportées mais qui sont pas encore
suffisantes qui nous permettent pas de
prendre en charge correctement les
patientes qui ne donne pas
d'attractivité à notre profession et
c'est ça finalement aujourd'hui qu'on
déplore cette augmentation de 183 euros
ok certes mais je veux dire c'est pas ça
qui va permettre d'attirer à nos futurs
collègues quand elles ont fait cinq
années d'études après le bac quelles
sont la responsabilité entre autres de
la vie des femmes et des enfants et de
la santé des femmes et de leurs familles
par la suite et que elles terminent
leurs études en pouvant espérer gagner
2000 euros bruts par mois s'est pas
satisfaisant on déplore un manque de
considération mais aussi un manque
criant d'effectifs plusieurs politiques
ont fait le déplacement pour soutenir
cette mobilisation deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22il
yannick jadot député vert et anne
hidalgo maire de paris la candidate ps
pour l'élection présidentielle 2022
yannick jadot a insisté sur le fait qu'
il fallait augmenter le salaire des
secteurs publics pour anne hidalgo la
maire de paris elle a préféré pointer du
doigt à la crise sanitaire qui a mis en
avant une fois de plus tous les
problèmes tous les maux de la santé
publique à crise sanitaire sur laquelle
tous les soignants ont fait tenir le
système de santé parce qu'ils se sont
arrachés la peau parce qu'ils ont pris
sur eux ils ont pris sur leur énergie
ils ont pris sur leurs compétences sur
le fait que ce sont des métiers de
passion ce qu'ils font et ça a tenu et
là on arrive à la sortie de cette crise
annie terre et on nous dit mais c'est
bon ça a été revalorisé banon parce que
sa part de tellement loin et le système
c'est tellement d'élite et que c'est pas
du tout suffisant et que ceux que posent
les sages femmes c'est vraiment
l'accueil au monde des tout petits il ya
eu ce travail fait par boris cyrulnik
qui est un travail exceptionnel sur les
1000 jours et on dit c'est exceptionnel
et tout le monde hier mais c'est
exceptionnel et bien traduit son cela en
attaque nous voulons évidemment
réhaussé revaloriser fortement les
salaires notamment les salaires d'entrée
dans les professions on voit bien que je
dire aujourd'hui une sage-femme qui
commence à 1600 avec des horaires
impossibles avec une charge
psychologique ils chargent de de
responsabilité sur la qualité de
l'accouchement du suivi des femmes il
faut absolument revaloriser ces salaires
repenser les formations recond c'est les
conditions de travail ce n'est pas
qu'une enjeux de salaires c'est aussi
parfois sur certains territoires un
enjeu majeur d'effectifs et des sages
femmes venues de toute la france de peau
de toulouse ii de cherbourg ou bien
encore de marseille l'objectif est de
mettre la pression sur olivier et veyran
et de se faire entendre cette sixième
journée de mobilisation ne compte pas
s'arrêter là puisque les sages femmes
tant qu'ils n'auront pas obtenu gain de
cause continuerons à manifester leur
colère dans les rues et à à lancer des
préavis à de grève comme ça a été le cas
le 24 septembre dernier
la crise sanitaire ailleurs en europe en
catalogne par exemple les discothèques
qui rouvre enfin après plus d'un an de
fermeture presque ininterrompu pour les
professionnels du monde de la nuit c'est
une victoire c'était le dernier secteur
économique être complètement paralysé
par la pandémie clémentine laurent
barcelone retrouve son ambiance festive
habituels les dix kodak rouvre enfin
complètement dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi cela faisait presque 18 mois
qu'elle n'avait pas retrouvé leurs
activités normales elle avait bien
ouvert en juin dernier mais face à
l'augmentation des cas de kobe de 19 en
catalogne elle avait dû refermer leurs
portes seulement deux semaines après
alors pour éviter le même scénario
gouvernement catalan a pris des mesures
les boîtes de nuit devront fermer à 6
heures du matin et pour rentrer il
faudra présenter le pass sanitaires les
discothèques ne pourront accueillir des
clients qu'à hauteur de 70 % de leurs
capacités et puis devront danser masqué
et enfin quant au baril seront tenus de
fermer à 3 heures du matin alors pour
les professionnels du secteur du monde
de la nuit c'est une très bonne nouvelle
même s'il peut sembler difficile de
mettre en place les gestes barrière de
les faire appliquer de manière
totalement strictes je vous propose
d'écouter ramasse le porte-parole des
syndicats des discothèques en catalogne
nous avons eu un peu de peur parce que
mon paillon qui a eu lieu il y aura
beaucoup de gens les gens veulent dans
ses volets vivre l'expérience d'une
autre fois la rentrée anticipée sont en
train de se vendre très bien la vente va
très bien et je pense que ça se fera sur
la route et les trois jours les gens ont
le téléphone n'arrête pas de tout le
monde de téléphoner tout le monde veut
les tables tout le monde peut danser
tout le monde veut écouter la musique la
réouverture des discothèques et bien
accueillie par les jeunes à barcelone
mais aussi par la mairie et me voilà une
possible solution aux rassemblements
festifs improvisés qui ont lieu le week
end depuis cet été en général ce sont
des jeunes qui se rassemblent dans les
parcs sur les plages ou encore dans les
rues et qui occasionne parfois des
dégradations des violences et la
circulation du virus est pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis barcelone
avec philippe emmanueli médecin français
cers ans en espagne c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
philippe-emmanuel y merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir là
catalan qui rouvre donc ses discothèques
mais avec prudence une bonne nouvelle ou
une hérésie d'un point de vue
scientifique pour le médecin que vous
êtes
non c'est une bonne nouvelle et c'est en
quelque sorte la récompense d'une
politique menée ici en espagne qui a
mené ses fruits et ce alors que le pass
sanitaire effectivement on pourrait dire
qu'ici c'est le pass des discothèques
parce que finalement son utilité va se
réduire aux entrées des boîtes de nuit
ça veut dire donc prudents repas
sanitaire évidemment à l'entrée des
boîtes de nuit pour vous c'est une
garantie
pour moi c'est effectivement le
prolongement de cette politique de la
responsabilité qui a été privilégié ici
c'est à dire qu on a imposé très peu de
mesures contraignantes à la population
ici je vous le rappelle il ne faut pas
de passes sanitaires pour rentrer dans
les grandes surfaces il ne faut pas de
passes sanitaires pour rentrer dans les
restaurants et effectivement l'espagne a
choisi de réduire l' usage de ce passe à
l'entrée dans des discothèques est en
quelque sorte ça fait sens puisque
effectivement c'est un lieu de
concentration particulièrement important
aujourd'hui philippe emmanuel dit
qu'elle est tout simplement la situation
chez vous en espagne et notamment en
catalogne
eh bien on peut dire que la situation
est comparable à celle de la france on
oublie le coville qui est qui revenu a
effectivement un taux de de reproduction
relativement faible et
c'est vrai qu'ici dans les rues de
barcelone on ne parle plus du virus
alors côté campagne vaccinale ceci
expliquant peut-être cela vous et nous
le confirmer ou non d'espagne fait
figure d'exemple un prêt de 85 % des
plus de 12 ans totalement vacciner idem
pour les seniors
se ce recul clair de la pandémie on le
doit à la vaccination en espagne selon
vous
oui clairement c'est l'effet direct de
la vaccination de la population et si
l'isf est également direct d'une
démocratie de la responsabilité qui
effectivement contrairement à la france
n'a pas voulu rentrer dans une stratégie
de contrôle mais dans une stratégie de
responsabilité est ici effectivement il
ya eu assez peu de polémique sur le
vaccin et la population aujourd'hui est
largement protégé comment vous
l'expliquez justement pas de polémique
sur sur le vaccin on sait qu'en france
les choses sont parfois plus compliqué
écoutez si c'est que c'est très
intéressant parce que ça touche un
phénomène culturel identitaire nationale
et ça dit beaucoup sur la france peut
être beaucoup plus sur la france que sur
l'espagne samedi que la france
aujourd'hui et probablement un pays en
proie à des crispations et que
effectivement il est difficile d'aller
vers dés débat apaisé de ne pas aller
vers les polémiques et ici en espagne au
fond ce qui comptait c'était
essentiellement un retour à la vie
normale c'était le retour à la fête et
au fond les gens se sont concentrés sur
ce retour à la fed plutôt que se
concentrer sur des polémiques
aujourd'hui chez nous un pass and it erp
notamment pour les enfants qui se sont
encore pour la plupart des enfants de ne
plus de 2 12 ans qui ne peuvent plus
exercer des sports à condition d'avoir
un passé militaire ou d'être vacciné
donc autant vous on est un petit peu
obligé de faire vacciner vous en tant
que médecin vous vous validez
moi en tant que médecin je suis
extrêmement
gêné par par ce type effectivement
de situation pour autant comme je
voulais déjà dit on est dans une
situation dont on ne connaît pas tous
les tenants tous les aboutissants il y a
donc un choix qui est un choix politique
avec des conséquences sanitaires et
personne aujourd'hui
ne peut te je dirais savoir
à 100% quelles sont les conséquences de
ses choix
aujourd'hui pour vous cette épidémie
elle est derrière nous philippe
emmanueli où il faut toujours rester sur
le qui vive et une énième nouvelle vague
serait probable
c'est très difficile à dire il faut
resituer cette épidémie dans le cadre
plus global des entrepôts zoonoses il
faut resituer cette arrivée du coc vide
si vous voulez dans l'émergence de tout
un certain nombre d'agents pathogènes
issus des maladies animales depuis une
vingtaine d'années le coc vide s'inscrit
dans ces maladies émergentes par exemple
comme le sida et simplement aujourd'hui
le coc vide a
fait émerger quelque chose qui a une
transmissibilité respiratoires et c'est
ce qui a fait effectivement la gravité
de cette épidémie donc
savoir si aujourd'hui cette histoire du
coc vie déterminée ou pas c'est je
dirais
restreindre l'angle de vue de la
question des maladies émergentes
parce que oui il faut s'attendre dans
l'avenir à avoir de plus en plus de
maladies émergentes c'est ce que nous
apprend aujourd'hui l'épidémiologie des
20 dernières années merci beaucoup fini
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
français exerçant en espagne merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur rt france
il en reste de l'actualité en tunisie le
parti ennahdha dans le viseur de la
société civile ong tunisiennes iwatch
veut saisir la justice une plainte
contre la première formation politique
pour corruption et financements douteux
lors de ses campagnes de 2014 et 2019 le
parti islamiste aurait signé des
contrats avec une société américaine
pour près de 400 mille dollars les
détails et avec ben hassen chébili à
tunis
le parti ennahdha de nouveau dans la
tourmente en pleine crise partisane est
pointé du doigt par une large partie de
la population qui le rend responsables
de la crise politique et économique que
traverse le pays le parti de rached
ghannouchi réputé proche des frères
musulmans ne semble pas en avoir fini
avec les problèmes dans le viseur de
l'ol jay walsh spécialisée dans la lutte
contre la corruption en tunisie la
formation politique est accusé d'avoir
accepté des financements directs ou
indirects de sources inconnues et de
parties étrangères l'omg a fait savoir
qu'en plus de contrats de lobbing conclu
par le mouvement avant les élections de
2014 et 2019 ennahda aurait signé
d'autres conventions avec la société
américaine burton master spécialisé dans
la communication et les relations
publiques une violation selon les ong de
la loi du 7 août 2015 relative à la
lutte contre le blanchiment d'argent je
vous propose d'écouter à mettre bedoui
conseiller juridique die watch
organisation et watch a détecté deux
contrats de lobbying au profit du parti
politique navx en date 2016 et 2018 donc
d'un montant total allant jusqu'à un
million de dinars donc juste il faut
préciser que lobbying en soi n'est pas
condamné mais le problème c'est doux le
financement de ces contrats donc on
trouve pas la trace au des traces de ses
dépenses dans les contrats financés au
les rapports financiers du parti navx et
donc il faut se demander d'où ce
financement et quels seront les impacts
de ce financement douteux sur
l'intégrité des élections et sur l'avis
des électeurs on va porter plainte pour
tout dépassement de la loi surtout la
loi électorale qui condamne et le décret
loi de 2000 hans qui organise les partis
politiques qui condamne tout tout
financement douteux est interdite des
financements étrangère et donc c'est ça
donc nous sommes entrain réellement de
chercher tous preuve pour toute preuve
peu pour que assurer un certain niveau
de transparence de la vie politique
à ce jour aucune réaction du parti
islamiste face à ces accusations alors
que la question du financement des
partis politiques semble refaire surface
depuis l'opération mains propres lancée
par le président sayed le 25 juillet
dernier c'est la justice tunisienne
longtemps critiquée pour sa lenteur dans
les dossiers de corruption sera scrutée
par une large partie de la société
civile qui se bat à l'image de loandjili
watch pour faire la lumière sont les
financements des partis politiques
tunisiens lundi le président ans sayyed
avait reçu au palais de carthage le
président du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour lui rappeler le retard
pris par la justice tunisienne pour
statuer sur les affaires de corruption
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
pour une prochaine émission à 20 heures
en attendant l'actualité continue
évidemment toute la soirée sur rtl
france
[Musique]
elle serait de retour en france
l'inflation en un an les prix à la
consommation ont augmenté d'1 9% selon
les dernières données de l'insee vous
avez aujourd'hui une impression qui est
plus due à une désorganisation simuler
des circuits de production et des
circuits de distribution plutôt que une
réelle inflation de la demande
l'inflation ressentie par les ménages ne
correspond pas forcément
à l'inflation qui est mesuré par l'insee
tout ce qui est prix de l'énergie loyer
et ses skis pestre